il ya des smartphones sur lequel on a
beaucoup de choses à dire il ya d'autres
sur lequel on a un peu moins de choses à
dire et celui-là ça smartphones sur
lequel j'ai moins de choses à vous dire
non pas qu'il ya pas deux choses
importantes et intéressantes à raconter
sur le mil neuf pros et chimie mais en
fait je vous ai des actes je vous ai des
artistes à commencer dès demain je vous
ai déjà quasiment tout le monde sur ce
1903 enfin à quelque chose près en fait
faisait déjà présenté il ya quelques
semaines le mil neuf des dix est le
petit frère du mineur et pro et je
regrettais quelque chose au sujet 2009
tél si vous voulez ce smartphone est le
top des performances c'est pas là dessus
qu'il faut et justement chez omi a revu
et corrigé sa copie avec le mit 9,0 en
lui apportant un regain de puissance
quelques points en plus je vous explique
tout ça vous allez voir c'est vachement
intéressant
[Musique]
on veut tout de suite extrêmement clair
extrêmement transparent le mineur est
pro n'est pas un nouveau smartphone on
n'a pas un nouveau design
on n'a pas un nouvel écran on n'a pas
nous de nouveaux haut-parleurs on active
on a tous déjà vu d'ailleurs si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas les invite à aller voir
la vidéo test 2009 des comme ça vous
saurez tout
oui à quelque chose près en fait celui 9
des pros il a été boostée vous allez
différence dans le pro pro généralement
sec plus de performance à redon pas que
ceci ne professionnelle si vous êtes un
professionnel vous pouvez l'utiliser
vous serez pas déçus il est parfaitement
bien il est chouette il est maîtrisé il
est top il est plein de belles
performances aviez vous de l'été ya
quelques instants mais surtout pro parce
que plus exigeants du pays plus
lointains mille de choses avec que vous
ne pouviez pas faire avec le 1900 alors
c'est vrai et pas vraies nouvelles plus
loin plus dans les retranchements plus
dans les recoins mais fondamentalement
ça change pas grand chose
alors avant de vous jeter sur le 1909
des pros réfléchissez à vos usages à ce
que vous allez faire avec à vos besoins
à vos besoins réels et concrets
est-ce que vous avez besoin de regain de
performance si c'est le cas alléchant
2009 des pros parce que vous allez avoir
plus de performance qu'est ce que vous
voulez faire regarder ce qui suit et
après vous me dire ce que vous en pensez
dans les commentaires
voilà comment ça se passe ici j'aime ont
mis neuf top-10 et pas une minute et il
a été rendu gars longtemps donc je ne
l'est plus ici j'ai mis 9 des pros mais
on va faire tout comme imaginons que
j'ai le mille neuf était je sais j'ai
final le minefe t il est là ici j'ai le
mil neuf des pros qui se situe là quelle
différence
je vais avoir entre le mit 9t et 2009
des pros déjà en termes de performance
parce qu'il est vraie différence en
termes de performance sur le minefe tgs
qu'on appelle le snapdragon 730 ça c'est
le processeur c'est en gros ce processus
est le coeur de votre machine
c'est là où il ya la puissance on est
sur un produit plutôt milieu de gamme
sur 1900 projet ce qui se fait de mieux
aujourd'hui tout est chez qualcomm
c'est le snap dragon 855
la grosse différence que j'abhorre c'est
qu'ici j'ai une puce qui est très
performant qui n'est pas énergivore qui
marche parfaitement bien et qui
permettra d'aller plus loin en terme
d'expérience mais c'est un dragon 855
part de faire des choses que vous
pouvais pas faire avec le sabre agon 730
exemple ici vous pouvez filmer des
vidéos en 4k à 30 fps
jusque là c'est plutôt cool et vous
pouvez pas le faire ici en 60fps c'était
strictement impossible avec celui là on
pouvait faire de la 4k kkr en 60 fps
sans aucun problème mais le fait d'avoir
un dragon 1855 à la place d'un 536 un
duo de choc samedi le fait vous êtes le
trouver la même caméra 48 mégapixels
parce que oui dans un cas comme dans
l'autre c'est une caméra 40 tubicam xl
mais c'est pas tout à fait la même parce
que avec l'ancien dragon 730 vous allez
voir une sony mx 5 182 et avec instinct
dragon 855 d'ailleurs sa grande soeur
c'est la sony mx 5 186 la différence
dans les tracés du point de détail c'est
minime peut-être même un visite pour
vous le faites pour filmer partons pour
le 4k à 30 images par seconde aux quatre
cas à 60 images par seconde vient
effectivement de cette différence a donc
la différence de processeurs induites
différentes caméras qui a dû au final
une petite différence de résultats pour
voir un peu le truc vous avez donc une
petite différence fait donc deux caméras
48 mégapixels l'une sera un peu moins
performante l'autre un peu plus mais une
fois de plus par rapport à vos usages
c'est probablement du point de détail et
après surtout ce que ça va induire cette
différence de processeurs pour le 730 et
le 855 surtout de la performance pure et
dure donc la question à se poser
aujourd'hui lorsque vous voulez changer
votre smartphone vous voulez sur soit
l'un soit l'autre c'est de réfléchir un
beau visage aujourd'hui et un veau usage
dirait dans deux trois ans l'idée c'est
ça un feu dragon's 155 sera plus
performant ira plus loin permettra de
faire plus de choses que ce que vous ne
ferait qu à sa dragonne 730 on
réfléchisse et si vous aimez jouer même
si vous voulez pas des titres hyper
performant aujourd'hui par exemple si
vous jouez avec un punch j ça marchera
très bien tout de suite avec les deux
smartphones ça sera un peu mieux avec
lui 155 mais réfléchissez surtout dans
deux trois ans et bien à ce moment là
vous serez content d'avoir 1 855 pts
aucun 730 parce que les jeux auront été
mis à jour seront probablement un jeu
plus gourmands et ça marchera mieux dans
l'avenir a déclaré 155 avec 1 732 qu'au
terme de temporalité et je sais pas
forcément va tout de suite mais aussi à
un peu plus tard c'est un conseil d'ami
tilly smartphone orienté gaming dit
smartphone qui peut potentiellement
chauffer justement vous avez une
différence aussi entre ces deux
smartphones
du côté du 1920 avait en refroidissement
une couche de graphène puurs anne-claire
pas plus pas moins
est-ce que sur le mil neuf des provinces
avaient huit couches de graphène pour
une meilleure dissipation de la chaleur
on imagine effectivement que lorsque
vous allez prendre un jeu qui va être
très gourmand que vous avez besoin
effectivement à ce moment là d'un
smartphone 855 que vous allez venir
chercher qu'il a chauffé davantage bien
vous aurez une meilleure dissipation de
la chaleur
c'est un peu tout l'intérêt sans 2009
les pros après vous allez également
avoir une différence au niveau du gps à
savoir que fin 2009 tv vous avez un gps
qui va être avec une seule fréquence est
ce que le gps sur le mil neuf des pros
lui aura une double fréquence noka
signal plus précis ici que là dessus
la différence également se mettre au
niveau de la recharge sans 1912 à les
avoir une recharge 18 watts tandis que
ça en 2009 les pros vous allez pouvoir
avoir une recharge 27 watts il va
pouvoir monter à 58 % en seulement 30
minutes de recharge donc ça c'est
vraiment cool maintenant la vraie
différence c'est que dans la boîte
vous n'avez pas un chargeur dit c'est
toi vous avez un chargeur 18 watts
exactement comme son ami 9t donc si vous
voulez le chargeur 27 watts et bien il
faut dépenser des dollars ou alors d
euros c'est à vous de voir mais après en
terme de performance pure je le trouve
un score sur en toutou qui est vachement
bien sûr tout où je lui trouvais un
score de jeu vous n'êtes là qui vous le
montrer et franchement il a absolument
pas à rougir 367 1845 ce qui est
vachement bien
ce qui le classe en fait entre le mit 9
qui est très bon et le black shark 2 qui
est un smartphone de gainey qui est
aussi très très bon ce qui veut dire
qu'en termes de performance devant un
tout qui est vraiment au top
mais attention le 1900 prônait 2009 que
le nom en réalité les lignes très pro et
lillers ce sont vraiment deux produits
différents que ce soit le 1900 et 1920
mans deux choses différentes il faut
vraiment les différences et c'est très
important
en fait ce 1909 des pros correspond aux
cavs 1 et aux caves un pro qui ont été
présentés en chine mais qui pour la
version internationale ont pris le nom
me lève tôt et 1935 le mans permettre
aux consommateurs de se repérer par
rapport à la dénomination 1009 mais le
9 me naphte et sont deux produits
différents donc le minfi dynastie pro
sont donc deux produits différents ça il
faut vraiment savoir
il est donc disponible en deux versions
vous est donc une version si j'y
viendrai plus de 104 de stockage au
tarif de 399 euros auraient été coûte 4
129 90 sous 1 30 euros d'offre de
lancement et vous avez une deuxième
version 6 giga de ram +128 giga de
stockage à 449 euros voilà tout
simplement donc si c'est un produit qui
vous intéressent moi je trouve bien
réfléchi c'est réfléchi c'est vraiment à
vous deux visages à vos besoins ça je
vous le dirai à chaque fois lorsqu'on
voulait faire un achat dans la tête ou
de charras en règle générale il faut et
encore plus dans la tête parce que le
produit va vieillir et les applications
risque d'être un peu plus gourmande en
temps notamment si vous êtes un gamer
donc si vous êtes un gamer
réfléchissez vraiment à ce que vous
allez faire il ya quand même une
différence de prix entre le 1900 et 1930
out pour le mil neuf des prouesses
vachement intéressant parce que l'armée
allait plus loin aujourd'hui à des
performances sont vraiment très très
bonne
et pour toute la partie photo toute la
partie écran jour on va bien évidemment
un bon test du mil neuf départs ce que
c'est exactement le même produit donc un
smartphone qui en fait juste sans
booster et d'ailleurs même très bien
sans but avoué hier en bas ce que vous
en pensez comment vous le trouvez celui
des petits pros intéressant oui non
recommandée est ce que vous avez acheté
le mil neuf top-10 si vous l'avez acheté
est ce que vous dites pas et mince si
j'avais su j'aurais attendu
dites moi tous ordres dans les
commentaires car à nous on se retrouve
demain pour les gros becs à bientôt